are you ready for the MCU to get a lot
bigger the Marvel's hits theaters on
November 10th and there's a lot to be
excited for we've got all the details on
the Marvels now the Marvel universe is
no stranger to crossovers even so the
Marvel's is sure to be a particularly
exciting crossover moment what the this
film will see Carol Danvers AKA Captain
Marvel Monica Rambo and Kamala KH aka
Miss Marvel join forces fans of all
these characters know just what it means
to have these superheroes getting
together you need all kinds of skill
sets all kinds of people with different
viewpoints and different backgrounds in
order to save the world yep these ladies
have all the bases covered when it comes
to superpowers and Camala who's Camala
hi she can turn light into physical
matter which I have never heard of
clearly these three are unstoppable and
it's basically the definition of girl
power and when it came to making this
crossover work it's clear that this was
on director Nia dasta's mind I find it
really interesting to three them
together and how they become a little
bit of a Sisterhood with their their own
like different points of view so it's
it's actually really nice and fun and
very sweet watching them all work
together this crossover is going to
bring together some seriously big heroes
and together they're going to use
teamwork to save the world I think it's
an incredible metaphor with this of
learning how to be in a team and also
like the very clear example that like no
one person can do it all the world does
not become a better place by one person
certainly not one lady these heroes are
used to being the leading lady but in
this movie there's no eye in team and
it's easy to see why that can be such a
good thing I didn't have to carry all of
it and I think that's part of what the
journey is for Carol in this is to
change the world can never just be on
one person it takes everybody to to play
their part and that's a huge part of
what this story is about we can only
imagine just how well these three are
going to work together no matter who
they're up against you realize that you
need a lot of different people with
special skill sets to come in and help
help get the job done they say you can't
fake chemistry when the Marvels is
proving that theory correct not only are
Carol Danvers Monica Rambo and Kamala
Khan teaming up on screen they seem to
be getting along just as well when the
cameras aren't rolling back to you and
back and back to you thank you Iman
checking in all right we're good all
right we're back weather's looking good
nice R LaRon Tiana Paris and Iman valani
are supporting each other through this
women-led project it sounds very
intimidating but these guys made it very
easy and we're very welcoming yeah good
and they're teaching each other a lot
along the way I learned from you to go
with the flow to have fun I mostly just
observe both of them because on Miss
Marvel I didn't know what I was doing
yeah they're a definite Dream Team I
feel warm and fuzzy watching you on
screen yeah we feel warm and fuzzy
watching these ladies become BFFs on
screen and off too of course we're all
excited to see the aforementioned dream
team of Captain Marvel Miss Marvel and
Monica Rambo but there will be more
characters in this movie both new and
returning that are sure to add some fun
Dynamics to the film Samuel L Jackson is
of course back as Nick Fury and his
character is said to be stronger and
greater this time around cigar Shake
returns as Amir Khan zenobi asra returns
as muniba Khan and Mohan kapor returns
as yusf Khan new additions to the MCU
include zoi Ashton as the film's villain
darb Ben par shojun is also appearing in
the film but role hasn't yet been
disclosed teamwork and girl power may be
the stars of the Marvels but like the
rest of the Marvel movies out there this
film would be nothing without the
incredible stunts and while cast bonding
on this set seemed to be easy the stunts
were not so easy movements aren't like
that difficult but it's doing it for
like 12h hour days repetitively that's
like you're using muscles that you
didn't even know existed luckily these
three are Old Pros by now for Captain
marel was like just being strong was
like such a huge part for me cuz I was
going from not being an active person at
all to being active and then was like
now it's like when you think about it
like if you could fly or even just hover
Would You Walk yeah she makes a good
point still we're not exactly jealous of
spending so much time being supported by
wires but you're fighting against
gravity and wires and it is
uncomfortable and it takes a long time
to go to the bathroom that's like a real
thing yeah these stunts required a lot
training with my trainer like twice a
day five times a week like that is a job
in and of itself now doing these
incredible stunts may not have been a
walk in the park but they sure did make
it look like it you want me to be like
basically being in a plank all day 50 ft
up in the air and you're like can you do
it better he like why don't you try
needless to say there are more than a
few things about the Marvels that have
us excited but it also might break a
Marvel record it's been reported that
this might be the shortest Marvel movie
to date it'll only be an hour and 45
minutes so it'll be short and sweet but
that's just what makes it ripe plenty of
rewatches now are you ready to get your
tickets to see the Marvels and theaters
what are you most looking forward to
seeing let us know in the comments and
for more videos like this one like And
subscribe to the
things